唉，你知道嗎？有時候看那些新創案例，我都覺得離我們好遠喔，都是什麼高科技，動不動就幾千萬幾億的投資。
嗯，確實有這種感覺。很多時候，聽起來是很厲害，但總覺得跟自己做生意、甚至跟自己的工作，好像搭不上邊。
不過，今天這個案例，我覺得很有意思，是一家叫做 bilt.me 的愛沙尼亞公司。他們做的是 AI 行動應用程式建構平台。
AI App 建構平台？聽起來還是有點距離感啊。現在這種平台不是很多嗎？它有什麼特別的？
差別就在於，它讓完全不懂程式的人，只要用「說」的，就能建構出客製化的原生 App。而且不只這樣，它還能幫你上架到 App Store 或 Google Play。
等等，原生 App？不是網頁 App 那種嗎？原生 App 的開發門檻很高耶，這點就出乎意料了。一般的 AI App 工具，很多都只能生成網頁應用。
對，這就是最不一樣的地方。bilt.me 的共同創辦人兼 CEO Uku Joost Annus 就說，現在網站雖然有十幾億個，但 App 只有幾百萬個，就是因為 App 比較難做。
嗯，這確實是事實。App 開發成本高，時間長，找工程師也不容易。所以他們是想降低這個門檻？但它具體是怎麼做到的？總不能真的靠 AI 憑空變出程式碼吧？
他們就是用 AI 代理人，用戶用簡單的語言描述 App 想法，AI 就會幫你建構。而且，他們公司只有六個工程師，還把他們自己開發 App 的過程在 Twitch 上直播。
只有六個工程師？這點也蠻值得注意的。這表示他們的核心技術很精簡，效率很高，或者說，高度仰賴 AI 來彌補人力不足。但 App 的穩定性跟效能怎麼辦？
他們已經打造了自己的支付、雲端和分享層，分別叫做 Bilt Payments、Bilt Cloud 和 Bilt Link。而且，用戶甚至可以匯出 App 背後的 React Native 程式碼。
喔，可以匯出程式碼，這點倒是給了使用者很大的彈性。表示這個 App 並不是完全被平台綁死，如果有需要，還是可以自己進行二次開發或維護。
是啊。所以它不是那種「一次性生成」的工具，而是提供了一個比較完整的生態系。他們甚至有免費方案，付費方案一個月也只要 13 歐元。
13 歐元？這真的非常便宜。如果中小企業主想做一個簡單的會員 App，或是活動報名 App，這個成本幾乎可以忽略不計了。
沒錯。Bolt 的創辦人 Markus Villig 也投資了 bilt.me，他就說，他 19 歲的時候，開發 App 是把想法變成公司最大的障礙之一。
他這句話就說到點子上了。對很多創業者來說，技術門檻確實是個大問題。所以 bilt.me 想要做的，就是把這個門檻搬走。
所以我覺得，如果我們是創業者，或是中小企業主管，這個案例就提醒我們，AI 工具不只可以用來做行銷，也能用來解決技術問題，幫我們快速驗證市場。
這樣說來，確實可以考慮。不用投入大量資金去養工程師團隊，就能在很短時間內把一個 App 雛形做出來，快速測試市場反應。
而且，不只創業者，一般上班族也可以把這個概念帶入工作或生活。你想想看，我們平常有很多重複性的工作，是不是也能找到 AI 工具來幫忙？
嗯，像是整理資料、生成報告，甚至是一些簡單的自動化流程，現在很多 AI 工具都能做到。這就好像把複雜的程式開發，變成說話就能完成一樣。
對啊，就是把那些我們覺得「很難」、「很專業」的事情，透過 AI 工具，變得「人人可做」。這感覺好像也提醒了我們，那些曾經被認為是高門檻的專業，說不定哪天就不是了。